Hi, I'm Remzi Senel.
I work at Gram Games.
Gram Games is a global
mobile game developer,
and I'm the head of
Mid-core Games [INAUDIBLE].
Today I'm going to talk
about how Google Play
platform enables us to react
fast, test our ideas fast,
and A/B test fast.
Gaming industry is
a dynamic industry
where things change fast.
One day you have
[INAUDIBLE] design,
and the other you have cute
bunnies jumping around.
So you have to track the user
interest and act accordingly.
So when we make prototypes
they are not always fun.
We don't want our every user
to see the prototypes we make,
so we use another developer
name to test our ideas
in Google Play platform.
We do that prototype Wednesdays.
Every Wednesday is a
prototyping day at Gram Games.
We try out our
new ideas and test
if they make it-- if
we can make them fun.
Once we are complete with the
prototypes on those Wednesdays,
we pack them up and send them
over to our friends and family.
Once they have the
game people tend
to sugarcoat their feedback.
They don't really
say what they think.
Well, it's fun, but
it's not for me.
What we are looking for
is that they show up
the next day at our office
with their eyes black,
having not slept last night.
When they show up with
their eyes black and eager
to play more of
the game, we just
take the game into our
production pipeline
and invest more in it.
If the game doesn't happen to
engage our friends and family,
we don't really invest.
What you're seeing is 1010!
World, our latest title.
It should be
launched pretty soon.
And what you see here is we
are testing different ideas.
For example, if the bombs-- you
see the green blogs over here--
do they make the users
get more into the game?
And what you see here is that
filling the board a little bit
more would be easier
or harder for the user.
When we do A/B testing
with different ideas
we try to observe the
behavioral changes in our users.
We try to figure out
which APIs went up
and which went down, and figure
out which works better for us.
Another thing Google
Play platform enables us,
is that we are free to iterate
it as fast as we can double up.
With other platforms
we really have
to wait for the review
duration, and when
you implement
something it takes time
to see the results of the test.
So with 1010!
World we soft launched
in three countries,
and every week we were free
to test our ideas with an A/B
test.
Every week we
implemented a new feature
and tested it out in the Google
Play platform in just a week.
We have launched 1010!
World to soft launch in three
countries two months ago,
and we have been A/B testing
rigorously for the better
half of the last two months.
So we went over 10 iterations
with the game, four completely
different art styles, five or
six different sound styles,
and thanks to Google
platform we are now
confident that our game will
perform well in app stores.